governor abbott joins me now from the
del rio sector of our border where the
ingram angle reported a few years ago
governor how will you get this wall
built
without the help of the federal
government
laura texas will build it ourselves
however
to tonight is not the night to announce
those details those details about
building the wall
will be made next week we've been
through the process however of
analyzing what it will take the steps
that are needed the legal processes
that are required we believe that we can
do it in a multi-step process
governor governor fine point like the
final point of laura listen we have we
have to build the border
i've been down here talking to the
people in the rio grande valley and the
way they are being overrun
is reprehensible is disastrous
uh what uh the bite administration has
done president trump had adequately
secured our border
he had to remain in mexico policy he
began building the border wall and now
suddenly all of that
disappeared and as you highlight it it's
led to a dramatic
increase and the number of people coming
across the border but it's not just
unaccompanied minors people are causing
great damage and harm to the residents
right here
in del rio as well as up and down the
entire border as a result
that's why i announced tonight a
multitude of actions that texas is
taking
including the fact that texas passed a
budget adding more than a billion
dollars for border security in the state
which is a good start but lara
also announced that texas is going to
begin
increasing arrests that are being made
arresting people coming across the
border
arresting people for trespassing and
because i've declared it a disaster
that elevates the penalty ensuring the
people that we arrest for trespassing
they will be serving time in jail we're
going to take this very seriously we're
going to do
everything possible to secure a border
including
building a border wall governor abbott
at some point i think we all have to ask
ourselves as americans
is this a willful refusal
to do what we know works i mean kamala
harris
a couple days ago said oh there's no
quick fix it's a complex issue go to the
root
problems go to central america give them
more money but we actually know what
works but they refuse
to do those things given that
do you believe this is purposeful on the
part of the administration
allowing this many people to come into
our country
i feel certain that it is willful it is
purposeful uh is wanting disregard
for the border laws for the immigration
laws for the border communities for
candidly anybody in the united states of
america the obama administration has
abandoned
the border any pretense of border
security any pretense
of enforcing our immigration laws
they've they've laughed it off just
the exact same way that the vice
president laughed it off
in our interview the other day and so it
is a joke
to the body administration but we're not
taking it as a joke in texas
we're going to step up and respond the
way we must respond
to secure the sovereignty of our state
to prevent the invasion that's taking
place
in front of our very own eyes and
governor
the speaking of laughing it off as you
describe
the vice president continues to embrace
her role overseeing the border
this was a cringe-worthy dodge tonight
by her
watch i've said i'm going to go to the
border
and when are you going to the border
vice president the administration has
asked i'm not finished
i've said i'm going to the border she
gets very snippy there
i mean she's had you know what 80
something days
and she hasn't visited an uh she hasn't
visited any part of the border
and she kind of gets she doesn't like
being asked hard questions she gets
very uncomfortable and she kind of blows
it off and insinuates that the reporter
has an agenda
by the way that's a i believe that was a
univision reporter
so they completely don't care about the
border at all
and they try to brush it aside as much
as they possibly can they ignore it
and they haven't come here they haven't
talked to us they don't want to do
anything for us
they're fighting us every step by the
way in fact the body administration is
now suing me
because of actions that i'm trying to
take to better secure the state of texas
to try to try to crack down on people
coming across the border so
they're fighting against texas efforts
to secure our own border
governor thank you for stepping up and
the people of texas
are spending an enormous amount of their
tax dollars
to try to secure their state but that
money should be that money should
ultimately come from the federal
government
in court and i'm sure you're looking at
all those avenues but thank you for
joining us tonight we're going to be
following this
obviously as we always have thank you
laura
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else